hey everyone welcome back to the show
this is rotten tomatoes is wrong very
exciting movie to talk about this week
but first uh jaclyn you and i were
having a conversation with our guest and
producer lucy about the random monies
that we have lying around our house or
for you and me in our travel bags and so
you were saying you have some canadian
money and some euros and some pounds and
some taiwanese and thailand money yeah
a spy you do you have like different
passports and stuff too is there like
some sort of
lock and key
the fbi is listening
as as are all of our certified freshies
everyone i just have i have nothing but
casino chips i have like like 200 in mgm
casino chips because it's always the
morning you wake up and you're like oh
god i gotta go to the airport and you're
hungover you don't have time to cash it
in and so you're like i'll be back so
tip people i tip people on the way to
the airport
much nicer than i am but probably not
our guest i'll tell you what's nice you
know what was nice kids the 1990s what a
time to be alive and what a time
to release a movie starring the world's
greatest basketball player still to this
day in my humble opinion we're talking
about space jam air jordan meets hair
jordan it came out in 1996 that's the
same year i got my driver's permit and
kids it's 43
rotten on the tomato meter it's a rotten
movie according to the tomato meter it
is 63 fresh according to the audience
score so there's a little bit of
redemption
you know
jacqueline when you talk about guests
who probably grew up in a time and we're
just sorting to really form opinions
about the world around them i think this
is the perfect movie for this next guest
because we have with us a rotten
tomatoes correspondent someone who is
just crushing it coast to coast doing
red carpets for e news and she's the
co-host of the podcast i don't get it
it's our good friend naz perez naz
welcome back to the show
hi guys wow mark i thought you were
going to introduce me like the tune
squad gets introduced you know coming in
at five foot two
i'm so excited to talk to you guys about
this movie because the fact that it is
rotten is like an absolute travesty in
my mind i was going to ask you so so you
think rotten tomatoes is wrong that is
your opening statement ron tomatoes is
so wrong that it makes michael jordan in
a baseball uniform look right like this
is one of the greatest sports movies of
all time it should absolutely not be
rotten it's a 90s masterpiece greatest
sports movies of all time naz coming in
with fire opinions that's why we love
her and jacqueline we're going to talk
about the movie scenes in space jam
whether they hold up whether the
soundtrack holds up i think we all know
the answer to that question and just
sort of the things that were going on in
1996 because it's such a fun time for at
least the three of us to remember fondly
cineburst and crystal well crystal pepsi
is probably already on the way out but
why don't you just go ahead and tell us
what space jam is actually about
okay kids let's take us back to a time
when michael jordan was not actually
playing for the bulls this was in his
retirement phase and during that time
there's some wacky mad cap aliens who
travel down to earth because they work
in a planet theme park which is run by
danny devito's
physical tune embodiment and the worst
parts of his voice before uh always
study in philadelphia anyway they come
down but they're little tiny alien dudes
and the tunes are laughing them they're
like you're gonna come work for us and
they're like no and he's like please and
he's like no it's like okay
basketball that's how we're gonna decide
whether or not you guys are going to
exist in tune slavery so bugs bunny and
his cast of characters challenge them to
basketball unknowing that these little
aliens have some technology to where
they rob the world's famous actors
charles barkley we're talking about
mugsy bogues takes their talent
puts it into the tiny toons and they
become the mon stars so bug says we
gotta get somebody good they get michael
jordan they spend most of the movie
getting michael jordan ready then they
have the big game bill murray shows up
for reasons and uh they win and save the
world and save the tunes and michael
doesn't have to be a sort of a
basketball slave as well and more
importantly it sort of like gives us an
excuse to then show michael jordan back
with the bulls
that is space jam and there's a song
which wasn't problematic at the time
i'll just leave it there
thank you for just just putting that
punch bowl front and center so to speak
so yes and thank you for referencing
early in the show but not the last time
we're gonna hear the name mugsy bogues
wake forest demon deacon
our own legend is sitting right here i
can look at her i don't know if you kids
can see her if you're streaming us if
you're listening to us you know both her
singing voice and her speaking voice
that is perducy lucy i'm sure space jam
hit you at a very important time in your
career yes i was six years old
and i loved it sorry
shut up i loved it this movie means a
lot to me yeah maybe it's one fancy
expensive commercial for a lot of
product placement but i still to this
day it's an easy re-watch for me i love
how fast it is and i'm actually a little
nervous about the new movie coming out i
don't i'm like oh i don't think it looks
as good weirdly
sorry okay i think a lot of people feel
that way lucy yeah
i i i definitely want to talk about the
new legacy that's coming out in a mere
matter of weeks or even days probably
based on when we release this every
movie is just product placement lucy
every movie citizen kane is just a
commercial for sleds there i said my
piece now let's go back to you to kick
us off here because tell us we clearly
know you think rotten tomatoes is wrong
about this that this should be a super
fresh movie one of the best sports films
of all time
particularly
with this movie in general why is it so
great and why is rotten tomatoes so
wrong
wrong tomatoes is still wrong because
first and foremost the plot that
jacqueline so perfectly said is just so
iconic in original af like it's it's one
of these high ideas that become fully
realized like i just picture two people
on their couch smoking a joint and being
like what if there was this alien
a voice by danny devito he lives on this
planet called [ __ ] mountain and they
want to steal the looney tunes to be a
main attraction there but then michael
jordan is going to save the world with
his talents because he's the greatest
basketball player of all time because
the aliens stole the talent from the
other amazing basketball players at the
time including including patrick ewing
who we haven't mentioned yet which i
feel like we just have to mention um to
me it's just like michael saves the
world through basketball duh one of the
greatest athletes of all time this was
his only major film role and he's
actually pretty good in it we all know
the soundtrack is fire it's gone
platinum like six times one of the most
shocking moments in sports was when he
announced his retirement from the nba
and he goes off to play baseball and
this movie plays off of that already
like not taking itself too seriously and
i feel like people think space jam takes
itself too seriously bill murray comes
in like jacqueline said for reasons
unbeknownst to us
to save the day
and it's incredible like it's amazing i
think it's perfectly we're in for kids
and adults it still holds up today
technically it was built on the you know
advancements of who framed roger rabbit
but for a lot of younger people that
were like born in the 90s i was six when
this came out too um i got this i'll
explain later like the first time i saw
it but
basically it's just i think it knows
exactly what it is and it delivers that
flawlessly and it was my first
introduction into seeing real humans
interact with cartoons it was also very
progressive in some ways i remember
being obsessed with lola bunny i was
like wow the best cartoon player on the
tune squad is a woman um the scene where
like the girls are making fun of charles
barkley because he can't play basketball
was just so incredible to me but the
most important reason space jam should
not be rotten and is just so iconic is
because it just became an inspiration
for kids to explore their full potential
i think in the 90s we all wanted to be
like mike and it get it gets pretty deep
at times and i think i'll i'll tell you
guys more about that when we talk about
our favorite scenes but it gets pretty
deep and for all those reasons i'm
obsessed with space jam and i don't
think space jam should be rotten
i think you're the perfect guest to have
on this show because it jacqueline we're
dealing with a couple youngins here i
mean they were six years old when the
movie came out we
and i'll say me have just a couple more
years of mileage on us so
do you think rotten tomatoes is right or
wrong about space jam
i think rotten tomatoes is wrong-ish i
want to have a podcast where i just get
to say wrong-ish right-ish because i'm
never i'm never like forceful for
someone that used to have was paid for
strong opinions now i'm like
i've mellowed in my age uh i talked to
two people born in 1990 jesus
uh no i think it's wrong-ish look it it
definitely is a product placement scam
it definitely is not winning michael
jordan any acting
uh awards but it's a movie for kids and
it's a movie for kids that despite all
of the things going around it and the
fact that michael jordan was likely
talking to tennis balls for the majority
of the film you still can find some
humor some pathos and it does enough
i think to make it worth something
although i will say
there's like a toonie that uh a looney
tunes movie uh that's their version of
fantasy island where all the tunes get
to like pick what their fantasy thing
would be that's the best looney tunes
movie don't get it twisted sorry space
jam but this one definitely it should be
higher
fresh-ish i think the audience score has
it about right um but i would give it
anywhere in those high 50s low 60s marks
um i can't live in a world where this is
better than constantine though so
take away
what an odd comparison i mean i guess it
is sort of the end of the world with
both of those movies in some regard and
so i'll give you that look we all know
the best looney tunes anything of all
time is not from bugs bunny or daffy
duck or marv of the martian it's
actually from that singing frog that
hello my baby hello my honey that is the
best looney tunes anything ever space
jam i'm gonna say rotten tomatoes is
wrong
because i think it should be higher than
43 percent
and i do have strong feelings about this
but where i actually land is somewhere
right in between rotten and fresh and so
i will use j if jaclyn said that rotten
tomatoes is wrong-ish i think that this
movie should be fresh-ish it doesn't
have to be fresh to make me happy but it
needs to be closer to fresh adjacent
than it currently is and when we talk
about this movie principally being a
product placement film i have another
theory on why this movie came out and
why this movie began as anything and it
has to do with michael jordan's psyche
we're going to get into that much later
in the show right now what we love
having here is someone who sets the
table as far as what the critics were
saying at the time this movie came out
way back in
1996 and for that we go to our expert
review curation manager tim ryan for our
segment two minutes with tim the floor
is yours
[Music]
tell us
[Music]
space jam was released a couple years
after the hair jordan super bowl ad and
michael jordan was the most valuable
pitchman in the world so a lot of the
criticisms of it at the time was it was
more of a branding exercise than
something that came about organically of
course that didn't really matter to the
kids who saw it at the time and doesn't
necessarily matter to those kids at this
late date the other thing that's odd
about space jam was it focused heavily
on michael jordan's minor league
baseball career thereby immortalizing
what's now kind of considered a footnote
in the story of his airness it's at 43
on the tomato meter with 76 reviews and
it has a 63 audience score so what did
the critics have to say in a rotten
review richard corliss of time magazine
wrote the movie could have been a
gleaming showcase for cartoon wit
instead it's an 87-minute commercial
peddling sainthood from michael jordan
however in a fresh review roger ebert of
the chicago sun times wrote it's an
inspired way to use and kid jordan's
image while at the same time updating
bugs bunny and company to doing battle
in the multi-zillion dollar animation
sweepstakes the rotten tomatoes critics
consensus reads while it's no slam dunk
space jam's silly looney tunes laden
slapstick and vivid animation will leave
younger viewers satisfied
though accompanying adults may be more
annoyed than entertained so that's space
jam and once you're done with this
podcast be sure to swing on over to
space jam's original website from 1996.
it's still online it's still there wow
okay we all got to go to spacejam.com to
go check out the latest and greatest in
the world of the information super
highway i'll see if i have 10 free more
hours with aol on that floppy disk that
they sent to my house so let's get right
into movie talk let's talk about this
movie the nostalgia the soundtrack let's
get into all of it so we should probably
have some music
[Music]
by the way don't think i didn't notice
that extended cut of producie lucy
belting out two minutes with tim i i
felt like that was that was
i i like the extended i don't like the
radio edits lucy i want the full
that wasn't that that was a good sport
lucy oh yeah yeah it wasn't going to be
two mins without it so i had to kind of
fill that time i literally wanted to ask
you guys because i haven't heard that if
that was lucy's lucy that's incredible
yeah that's amazing so cheesy what are
you kidding that's like it's hard having
to sit here and watch everybody's face
no i'm obsessed
it's like giving me richard simmons
vibes who by the way also makes a cameo
on space jam they're playing
a 90s masterpiece but i digress
it is a 90s masterpiece in certain
regards and i think a lot of that is
just the nostalgia is is how we came
upon this movie because i know that
michael jordan still has sort of a
looming presence over the world of
basketball in the world of marketing and
he came back into the forefront when we
needed him the most during the pandemic
with the last dance and so he's
omnipresent now but he was in your face
everywhere you could not escape michael
jordan in the 1990s not just because of
his incredible basketball prowess in the
90s chicago bulls but through gatorade
nike air jordan all of that stuff he was
just everywhere and so when this movie
was announced and when it was released
for me anyway i don't even remember
blinking an eye being like oh that's
weird he's in a movie it's like no this
makes perfect sense because this guy's
everywhere else so why wouldn't he be
hanging out with the looney tunes we
already loved the commercials looney
tunes on their own had made a 90s
resurgence in thanks part to going back
to nasa's point who framed roger rabbit
and so the first time i came about this
movie i don't know that i saw it in
theaters i think i might have waited to
rent it jacqueline naz and nas let's
start with you because you were only six
years old did you see this movie in
theaters
no my parents were so generic i never
even had real fruit loops until like a
couple years ago everything in my life
was generic i saw every movie like two
years after it came out at the dollar
theater in florida
all old people in it but i will say when
i was thinking about because we had this
question before he started recording and
it actually made me really sad when i
was thinking about the first time i saw
space jam so i was seven years old
because it came out on vhs in march my
birthday's in march and so for my
seventh birthday in 1997 i actually was
gifted the vhs for my birthday and i and
i just want to talk about that feeling
of like getting that plushy plastic vhs
like in like a birthday bag it makes me
sad that you can't tangibly really give
someone a movie today um but anyway so
it was gifted to me for my birthday so i
watched it a bunch obviously like
rewinded a bunch and that was the first
time i saw it was when i was seven
uh jaclyn did you see space jam in the
theater
uh i did not see space jam in the
theater if i recall correctly this was
just in that
yeah if i recall correctly this was in
that phase where just a little bit too
old to be like i'm gonna go run to see
space jam that being said i did have the
space jam soundtrack um yeah yeah on
on cd and i remember getting that very
early because it had the quad city djs
and seal on it which i was like all
about and i think i ended up seeing it
television like either hbo
i was an only child so i was like the
only kid in my neighborhood that had
cable because that was my mother's that
was my mother's uh placation for a lack
of siblings it came out right before
thanksgiving in november of 1996 which
is very interesting timing i also own
the soundtrack you know who else on the
soundtrack my high school basketball
team that was pretty much our warm-up
tape with certain songs through my
entire basketball career when because i
was probably let's see i was 16 by the
time the movie had come out and so it
just it was right in my high school
basketball playing heyday and so you
just you were so aware of it even if it
wasn't the movie that you were rushing
out to see it was just a cool thing to
have around knowing that michael jordan
was still there and he had come back to
basketball the previous season so when
we talk about scenes in particular it
might be odd to hear my favorite scene
in this movie has nothing to do with
basketball it's actually when they're
playing golf it's wayne knight bill
murray larry bird and michael jordan
which if you wanted the most
entertaining golf foursome of all time
it's a pretty good place to start you
think i got a shot
come on really no don't kid me listen
it's a man's game
and you can't play what if i tried
really hard can you keep it down i'm
trying to hit this ball
it's because i'm white isn't it
no that's why so what
larry's not white
larry's clear
gotcha boy get inside of his ball
you clowns can't beat that it's the best
shot i ever hit you haven't been playing
long it's a hall of fame shot nice shot
mr bird larry please and that's the
scene early in the movie where we
have the looney tunes trying to recruit
michael jordan
to be
air jordan again he's playing golf he's
chilling bill murray's got some great
lines in there and michael lo and behold
reaches into the hole and then he goes
down the proverbial rabbit hole
literally meets bugs money and we're off
on our adventure that scene to me has
the best comedy for the adults that
maybe took the kids to go see the movie
and it also it just there's nothing i
love more than bill murray on a golf
course when you throw in the other three
fellas it makes it that much better naz
what is the scene to you that you say
that that right there is why rotten
tomatoes is so wrong can i just comment
on what you just brought up because you
have to bill murray's wardrobe is iconic
like that umbrella hat is that i need
one like i must own one and you're
absolutely right like the comedy that
comes from that the awkwardness of like
wayne knight and like when he has the
disposable camera and bill murray's like
don't point that lens at me
every bird's like where'd he go it's so
good um when it comes to like favorite
scenes there's so many but like i think
the one that's most important to me
which i alluded to earlier which i think
was sort of deep for space jam i think
now watching it as i'm older
is the secret stuff scene so when the
tune squad it's half time and i also
just love you know when when we watch
any basketball game in general um and a
team is down and they come back from
halftime and they're just like slaying
it you're like man what was said in that
locker room that just turned everybody's
mindset around and in this case in the
game and space jam it was the secret
stuff scene where bugs bunny you know he
fills up a water bottle of water from
the sink and he tells mj to play along
and they basically convinced the team
that it's michael's secret stuff it's
the reason why i bought this
water bottle i'm actually holding one i
own one and the reason why it was so
deep for me is because i think it was
for many of us one of our first
interactions with handling like the
dreaded imposter syndrome like i feel
like we were able to take away from this
movie that no matter like how bad you
might have felt about your circumstances
that you need to give yourself a fair
shot at achieving what you think is
possible and i think that is what
michael jordan embodies to me that's why
he's like literally on the background of
my phone like i that's like what he
represents so to me that's like my
favorite scene yeah finished a great
speech and all doc you had him riveted
but uh didn't you forget something
what
your secret stuff
[Music]
wow
whoa nice deltoid play along
and then if i had to pick another one
it's the opening scene and montage of
little michael playing basketball
shooting outside his house after
midnight and his dad's like what are you
doing and he's like i want to play for
north carolina and he makes a shot and
he's like and then i want to make it to
the nba and then he makes another shot
he's like and then i want to play
baseball just like you and then we get
this montage of like michael just flying
and being incredible and i think what
people fail to realize about space jam
is that it is like this mini slice of
biopic like we were so invested in who
michael was in the 90s he was the
superhero he was the leader of the us
olympic team he was in michael jackson's
music video he was you know
in the like my commercials and so
because we got a little bit of his
actual real story i think that's what
people fail to realize is that's what's
so cool we get a little bit of michael's
story along with a cartoon movie for
kids and adults and i think lucy that's
why people are sort of hesitant about
new legacy because it's like are we
gonna get to see lebron and like you
know i i would like to see little little
lebron in like akron ohio you know be a
part of like that storyline who knows if
we'll get that but anyways those are my
two favorite scenes and you get those
emotional tinges that we referenced too
jaclyn because again michael jordan lost
his dad a couple years earlier under
tragic circumstances and so seeing him
interact with his old man even in this
cartoon movie what it's going to become
it's still at least if you know that
backstory and you know how much he loved
his dad have some emotional weight right
from the get-go yeah also shout out to
tom berry who's the actor that plays
michael jordan's father he's like a face
that folks will recognize from like a
lot of like popping up and stuff he was
in part of the fast series he also was
in like west wing and stuff and he's
just like a kind of doing his own thing
character actor but he really gives it
in that opening scene and also the young
kid that plays
uh michael jordan at age 10 brandon
hammond because he is like was the kid
actor for like black kids for like most
of the 90s he was literally in
absolutely everything and i think for me
the part of the movie that i
particularly liked was because they cast
michael he was actually really big about
including those touches he really wanted
it to feel like this wasn't just gonna
be a cash grab and that opening scene
shows it and then the scene with his
family shows it you know having jim rome
talk trash about him this was back in
the dirty boys of espn days where they
very much um i think said things with
impunity
and it was just interesting being like
look his kids watch this stuff so like
there's been things said about every
major athlete that i think showing that
dynamic and where he's like you don't
need to watch this watch watch the tunes
instead also theresa randall and you
know they they did they made michael
jordan as big of a star as he is still
an unapologetic black man even though
he's you know fighting against a bunch
of
looney tunes because i think there's a
caricature that you could make about the
monstars that's not really great but
they again they were careful i think to
balance the two it is still a movie of
the 90s though so we'll get into that
later do the basketball scenes hold up
in your opinion and i'm going to
juxtapose that against michael jordan's
acting because he was
it was mostly green screen i mean it's
not like unfortunately for all of our
listeners bugs bunny and daffy duck
aren't actually real well the bunny
doesn't actually exist i'm sorry this is
the first time you're hearing it so
michael jordan is basically playing off
of a green screen or a bunch of dudes in
green suits or tennis balls and so i
think given that hurdle for somebody
who's never acted professionally other
than in commercials before i think he
did a good job and especially we know he
has basketball skills and this is also
at the time when he is mounting his real
life comeback into the world of
basketball and so to see that you're
literally watching his body rebuild
itself for basketball shape before our
eyes in this cinematic universe so i
actually think that the basketball
scenes hold up pretty well
yeah i think the basketball scenes are
the thing thing about it that still
holds and it's just funny that
unfortunately it takes a long time to
get there yeah i clocked it when i was
watching it last night it's almost an
hour before we're actually like in the
game and you know we got a nice you know
five minutes that we have to spend just
spending time um
telling uh just introducing the the tiny
toons folks you know what i mean like
the way they used to introduce the bowls
with like the music and the stuff like
they got to give them all their do
um but once the basketball starts it's
actually really fun really funny and
also showing like look dude you can
literally get dominated on the court
even as the best player and just the
funny ways they found to be inventive
for them to score
uh against the monsters i also thought
was really great and yeah no it felt
like you were you were watching a
cartoon
heightened reality version of it but it
was still fun and i hadn't remembered it
from the last time i watched it and i
was like where did when did they get to
the fly seat like where are we gonna go
like how many different ways are we
gonna go to get there
it's funny too because you're right it
does take a long time to get there but
once he walks out once they get his
shoes which i just love the looney tunes
interacting with his kids too or just
humans in general but um once they get
his shoes and he walks out and he's like
let's play some basketball and then fly
like an eagle by and i know we'll talk
about the soundtrack later but it's just
such a perfect scene where he's just so
in his element and it's just i don't
know he's like immortal in in some way
in that moment i love it i i agree i
think michael jordan absolutely holds
his own um i don't think he's like
trying too hard and i think that's
really hard to do i i know most people
when they get in front of a camera or
when cameras are pointed at them
they feel like they have to maybe be
like an over exaggerated version of
themselves or they have to turn
themselves on so imagine having to play
against looney tunes like looney tunes i
would imagine the average person would
try and like be even larger and he's so
charming yet unapologetic he's so
himself like when he when he um tells
all the basketball players to touch the
ball and he's like i'm seriously going
to regret this you know it's like that's
so michael jordan like he doesn't want
to give them their powers back but he's
doing it because it's him and it's the
right thing to do
i i was actually like astounded by like
how
how grounded he is as michael in this
film like you were saying i they
definitely had um they definitely
brought in some comedic actors i think
to for for him and bill murray to play
against but the basketball scenes are
the best and the fact that he made that
half court shot you know by stretching
his arm out will like forever live in my
mind rent-free
i say we get into the soundtrack i say
we bust it open wha what are the tunes
on here that that really keep you coming
back for more what are the ones that
inspire you what are the ones that make
you contemplate what are the ones that
remind you how much you love space jam
the first time you saw it yeah so for me
obviously um you know and i think
jacqueline you were like alluding to
this earlier too
uh i believe i can fly
and this film has such a symbiotic
relationship that when i think back on
the film i'm like did did the movie get
really big because of the song or was
the song really big because of the movie
but now everything that we've learned
about r kelly it's like
it's it's hard to like put in
perspective like this really uplifting
and resonant song that meant so much to
people in the 90s i remember this song
being played at graduation like at my
church you know people would people
would play i believe i can fly all the
time and i again i don't know like which
one
it's like a chicken or the egg thing
um
so yeah it's hard to grapple with now
like obviously that's like a whole
separate conversation um now learning
everything that we know about r kelly um
but that song is and the movie is very
much they're very much linked um for me
my favorite is jock jams um it just
reminds me of like
i mean just the four words y'all ready
for this and it's just like nah nah nah
nah nah like i just think of like every
cheerleading competition that i watched
in florida like jock jams was just like
the jam of the 90s it was the soundtrack
of our childhood i feel like uh if
you're asking me about the soundtrack i
just want to mention to everyone again
that chris rock is on this soundtrack
for reasons because uh he helped with
the um
with the uh
barry white song basketball jones which
is sort of like the lola bunny bugs
bunny anthem so
the man has many talents also
for me though it's for you i will by
monica that is actually my favorite one
um it was you know back in the 90s r b
phase like monica and brandy did that
boy's mind and became the hit but both
of them have their own filmography and
for you well it's definitely a top one
on that one and still shout out to quad
city djs man
let's give it up at the space jam come
on that is a pop that is a bop and so
unproblematic to this day so it's
interesting too and the only thing i'll
say about the whole r kelly thing is
that
unfortunately it was this song and the
image that he portrayed in it that
allowed some of the other stuff about
him to remain under the surface
and so i think it's just like it's hard
to listen to the song now even though it
still has that sweeping moment the music
is still incredible
you realize that unfortunately that kind
of funded in a lot of ways some really
horrible atrocities that happen to a lot
of women um obviously that has all been
talked about in the press and it's not
you know breaking any new ground to say
that but yeah it definitely changes the
way the song ages also lola lola's a
little bit different this this time
around when i watched it i don't know
did you were you feeling lola back at
those times uh mark
i was i was feeling the seal song fly
like an eagle arguably even better than
the steve miller fly like an eagle and i
loved hit em high the uh the monster's
anthem is also pretty cool so yeah
that's a good one yeah this was this was
more for me than obviously too unlimited
with the would get ready for this just
because that was like our high school
gym what we just had like
like a boom box was was our sound system
and so you couldn't really crank it too
well but i remember we went on the road
somewhere we played like it might have
been like the math or like one of the
like real high school basketball
powerhouse factories we did not win the
game but coming out we had they had like
a whole sound system and they played get
ready for this and it was just like i've
i've never been so hyped up for a game
just because you just could feel that in
your bones it was so cool and again part
of you is thinking about space jam when
it happens and so
this is
that soundtrack took on a life of its
own i think it went six times platinum
something like that it peaked at number
two on the billboard chart people debate
whether it's the best movie soundtrack
of all time i think it's it's worth
consideration and so it just adds into
both
the movie itself but i think it also if
people are looking for barbs to throw at
this movie then they would say it's
you're just a movie that is here to sell
michael jordan to the masses and to sell
a bunch of soundtracks which it
ultimately did and to jaclyn's point
earlier i mean i think that's the
biggest issue i have with this movie is
that it does take us so long to get to
basketball we're having fun with the
looney tunes and and and watching the
humans come together and some of the
animation is really well done the way
that they combine humans and cartoons
but at the end of the day it's like hey
we're here to win a very important
basketball game can we please get to the
heart
a little bit faster is is there anybody
else in the movie whether it's cartoon
or an actual actor that stands out to
you i'll start with you nas who who else
in this movie
we mentioned michael jordan lowa bunny
everybody loves bill murray who else in
this movie were you like oh yeah that's
one of my favorite parts well daffy duck
is hysterical and i don't think he gets
enough i really don't think he gets
enough praise like he's actually so
funny i only want to watch daffy
interact with people more and like i pic
i think this movie still holds up today
because there's a lot of jokes i didn't
pick up when i was little watching it
like when they're trying to get
michael's shoes from his house and bugs
is like you know all those lunch boxes
with our faces on it have you ever seen
any money from that stuff and he's like
man we got to get new agents and it's
like that stuff just went way over my
head and it's so good they even do a you
know they even take a little stab at
disney and they're like what kind of
mickey mouse organization would name
their team the ducks you know so just
shout out to um daffy he's hysterical
also my first introduction to danny
devito was through swag hammer before he
was phil in hercules the year after so
love that but
for me it was charles barkley if michael
jordan is bugs bunny charles barkley is
daffy duck to me and i like that they
played on their relationship because in
the 90s if anyone defined bromance in
the nba it was like michael jordan and
charles barkley and i mean they like
played golf together i think in the 1993
nba finals that's how close their bond
was until i think i don't know it all
sort of michael jordan tends to hold
grudges
he's like
that's all i needed and then he like
held a grudge forever but so i like that
they played on that where you know
michael jordan travels to the cartoon
world and he becomes this hero and
barkley gets like the talent sucked out
of him and he gets called like a clown
and he was you know trying to convince
his therapist that everything he had
been through wasn't a dream it was just
i think it was just really cool how they
like sort of played on that so um shout
out to charles barkley because he wasn't
terrible he was not terrible
who else in this movie really
lights you up when you see it i mean
it's an easy answer he's in here as i
said four reasons but bill murray gives
a pretty great performance this was i
think in bill murray's like you know was
it operation dumbo drop was that him
what was there was like a weird phase of
building a larger than life yeah larger
than life elephant movie that's what it
is and so he like had
this phase of doing like kid movies
where i think he was just like i'm bill
murray and i don't care we didn't get
paid that much for ghostbusters let's
just have a good time
and
even though that's what this is he's
still really funny in it he's still so
great like you're the duck like i that
was on the commercial and for obvious
reasons so yeah yeah no i really liked
watching um bill murray in this i'm not
a seinfeld person i i just now started
watching that show like because i was
told i need to but um
so i didn't get the wayne knight thing
at the time um and i don't now but he
was definitely fun as well but uh i
guess my favorite person is theresa
randall i love her and everything
um shout out to girl six which is the
spike lee movie you need to watch it
it's amazing
and yeah i i will i will enjoy her in
everything
especially bad boys
i just i love seeing all of these 90s
nba stars again in their prime
particularly people like sean bradley
who's seven foot seven you have larry
johnson grandmama horse had a great
commercial campaign with that in the 90s
obviously as a fellow awake forest guy i
love seeing mugsy bogues in there
interesting that our arch rival north
carolina has the alum michael jordan who
would put mugsy bogues at demon deacon
in his movie as you look at the list of
famous nba stars that are in this not
one from duke he didn't put anybody from
duke in there he ain't giving christian
latener a call he's not having danny
fairy pop into this movie who's giving
christian leighton her call though even
at this point he was already a joke
great
question can we give a shout out but
like can we just mark give a shout out
to all the players you just mentioned
because i also feel like they hold up
their own too as someone who had high
hopes for the film uncle drew who i
really ended up not loving unfortunately
um i was like wow mugsy like all these
guys are they're really in the movie and
i love how they they you know it's
almost like space jam goes through a
pandemic in a way you know where they
shut down the nba they try and figure it
they're wearing masks instead of
changing in the locker room they're
talking to their therapist they're going
to the psychic like it's all super funny
and i think actually really well done
and they're they're believable like when
they're saying things they're believable
to me
yeah
so i i want to end movie talk in a
little bit of a different way here
before we move on to some behind the
scenes talk real quick are you all
excited or are you hesitant about space
jam the new legacy because it's
obviously lebron james taking over for
michael jordan as the role of the
greatest basketball player on planet
earth who's probably going to have to
defend it looks like he's more the
father though as michael jordan was the
son in this movie because
the they're trying to i think they're
literally trying to kidnap his son
they're trying to steal his son they're
trying to steal brawny and so lebron
james has to
stop that with the help once again of
the looney tunes from what you've seen
so far is this something you're excited
to see or are you like ah you know what
maybe we shouldn't have messed with the
original legacy start with you
jacqueline
um i'm not worried about this one but i
don't have the emotional investment like
friends of ours do but i also feel
this movie's just gonna do fine like
it's gonna do fine the people who are
gonna sign up because it's lebron are
going to sign up the kids who are going
to want to see it because it's the
looney tunes and they want to see the
looney tunes and everyone in between is
going to find space for this movie it
hits too many quadrants i feel to just
be a complete flop will it be enjoyable
depends on who you're asking i think the
eight-year-olds are gonna give it two
thumbs up no matter what it's gonna be
certified fresh in their book
i'm curious to see if there are any
adults who really champion this movie
the way roger ebert did at the time when
this space jam came out so i i i think
we know why roger ebert championed this
movie he's he's he's a legendary film
critic he's also a chicago guy so this
is true
this is true criticize michael jordan
too much naz are you yourself excited
for the new legacy are you concerned
about it
do you do you put any emotional weight
behind the new space jam i'm always
excited because i love space jam and i
think fans of this film have been
wanting like a sequel to this for a long
time um whether or not i'm gonna be like
obsessed with it or emotionally attached
to it it's obviously not gonna be
nostalgic for me so it'll never be like
above the original in my mind
um i agree with all the points jaclyn
made i think it i think it'll serve what
it needs to serve my only concern is
what i mentioned earlier is that a big
reason why i loved it is because we just
got like a little sliver and investment
into michael's story
and i don't know from what i've seen so
far maybe i'll be maybe i'll be
surprised walking out of the theater if
we're gonna get that like with lebron
and that's i love lebron for all the
reasons
a lot of people love lebron like what he
was able to do and and just his story is
what i am invested in and so um because
we got a little bit of that in space jam
with michael jordan
um i'm hoping to get a little bit of
that in new legacy with lebron but it
doesn't seem like we will from what it
is
yeah i i don't i don't really and it's
it's odd to hear me say because i am a
huge looney tunes fan and i obviously
watch the nba all the time i'm a huge
live sports fan particularly the nba and
i just don't find myself really caring
that much about the new movie i will see
it because i love watching nba star
cameos like that and i and lebron
he may not ever pass michael jordan as
far as goat status i think it's still in
doubt but i think he's
proved himself as a pretty capable actor
he was really good in train wreck and
yeah i think that there's a big
difference between lebron where he is in
his career versus where mike was in his
career during the making and release of
space jam so i want to talk about that
on the other side as we transition into
behind the scenes
[Music]
yeah so this is so
this is this is what i hinted at up top
i think that the reason why this movie
was made sure was it was to make a
billion dollars into merchandise and to
capitalize on michael jordan's name and
to sell soundtracks but i think it was
also in no small part mike doing what
mike does to himself best giving him a
hurdle to climb over giving him fuel for
the next season because he knew he's
coming back to basketball while he's
making this movie they made this movie
in the summer before the season began
that was his full first season back with
the chicago bulls and he knew given the
premise of this movie that um this
movie's going to come out after this
season i'd better win the championship
because it is not going to look good
with this movie being released in
november if i am not once again
a world champion and he managed to
accomplish that lebron james on the
other hand
um he's not a world champion when this
movie comes out and the lakers had a
pretty uninspiring exit from the
playoffs he was banged up anthony davis
was banged up and got a lot of criticism
for how long he was out anthony davis is
also in this movie so i think the
dialogue around this movie is gonna be a
little bit different not quite as
celebratory because we're not bringing
in a championship that's just me and my
basketball mind thinking about the
difference between the new legacy and
this movie well mark hopefully we get
some cameos from other awesome like
basketball players in the way we did
with the original i think that could
really like
leave people feeling really great about
it i hope so yeah yeah i mean i know we
get damien lord is going to be in it as
well diana taurasi is in it they're so
there there's a lot of great ballers
that are going to be in this movie i'd
love to see a kobe shout out i think me
too
me too i was just thinking that um i
actually just want to make this really
clear because since we're talking about
the new age and you mentioned train
wreck and like we're not gonna take an
opportunity to not bring up my husband
because he said and i told you about
lebron james bill hader said when he was
doing press for train wreck and this is
why i actually have a little bit of more
hope about it he said this guy literally
did things that i went to school at
second city
in l.a to learn how to do like improv
not to to to to just do the yes and and
just to have that like quick on your
feet he's like i guess when you have
basketballs coming at your head
you're already in sort of a heads up
mode already and he just applied that to
his comedy and he said it was honestly
disconcerting how good he was at doing
this so
i'm actually going to hold out hope that
it won't that if and nothing else the
acting will step up because his
performance i don't think of judd apatow
as some incredibly
gifted actorial director to just pull
the greatest performances out of
everyone
i think he's just got that natural
talent that's probably why he chose to
come to la and started his studio which
already has like 15 projects in the
works
it's so funny to go back and look at
where we were in 1996 too just with
everything going on
in in that world the most watched show
when space jam came out was er starring
a young man named george clooney who
went on to some acclaim i'm told
afterwards this was the year that we
cloned a sheep this was the year that
the spice girls had a number one album
which was
wannabe and get this motorola had just
introduced this crazy new phone called a
star track that would start track there
was a flip phone it was a flip phone and
it's like oh my god we're going mobile
this is nuts
yeah when did the razer come out because
i do remember razer
uh
envy i don't know brian if you're
listening help me out here or loosen the
razor
side kick too i think the razor was like
the early 2000s yeah i had a razor in
high school which was like 2004 to 2009.
that was when i first felt phone envy
that in the actually no the sidekick
yeah t-mobile sidekick that was when i
first felt phone nb before that i was
just happy to have a phone but it was
the sidekick because like that flipping
aspect i died when i think it was i
think i honestly saw who had a sidekick
i don't know but somebody famous had a
sidekick and they like clicked it out in
an interview and i was just like
yes is this when we had like pokemon
cards and gel pens and butterfly hair
clips and just gigapads and yeah yeah
all that stuff in grade school can you
name it do you know who the who who was
the host of the daily show when space
jam came out craig kilbourne
craig kilbourne is the answer the former
espn sports center anchor and then went
on to
host the daily show which we still did
not get because we did not get comedy
central in my house for quite some time
until we upgraded the cable package well
after i had gone off game to college i
was downloading oh wait i have to tell
you this i was downloading south park
episodes on dial-up internet modem
not kidding you do you want to know how
long it was to get the like it like they
killed kenny it was
hours to get one like a 15 minute south
park episode you killed kenny again you
bastard yeah oh my god
so great i do want to say because this
research was pulled for us and i think
it is um a fun thing to know but the
1990s were massive for pg rated sports
movies and sports movies in general and
i lowkey wish
that this would like come back in some
way and i think that's why i'm really
excited for a new legacy because i'm
someone who like the sandlot's one of my
favorite movies of all time cool
runnings like is one of the greatest
films ever made sometimes i can't even
believe it that actually happened that a
jamaican bobsled team like went to the
olympics and like i wish movies like air
bud and the big green and the mighty
ducks and like a league of their own
like all these films it was just such a
time for this
so it'll be interesting to see if like
if a new legacy is successful if that'll
create like a new interest in in
bringing like sports films back
to the big screen in a big way like
angel's in the outfield
you're right and even just just limiting
it to basketball the 90s were pretty big
for for basketball movies like you
mentioned as i mean you had you had i
what i consider the greatest sports
movie of all time is white men can't
jump from 1992. uh hoop dreams which got
robbed as it wasn't even nominated for
best documentary when it was clearly the
best documentary of that year you have
the air up there which people have blue
chips i think you can go back and watch
blue chips speaking of athletes becoming
actors that had shaq and penny in it
right when they were entering the nba
and that movie holds up so well in terms
of how dirty college basketball is with
nick nolte yeah yeah yeah yeah but you
have to also mention um kazam right
kazam
yeah it and that was when shaq was full
on like yeah i'll take the paycheck i'll
do i'll do the role because he was
saying
steel
somebody wrote about steel recently and
it was actually really interesting as
like a heartfelt little love letter it's
like
steel is not a good movie but its heart
was in the right place and it and they
like kind of broke down how it was
really trying
in earnest to give a black panther type
moment to kids back in the 90s it just
didn't have any of the tools and nobody
involved in it had the skill set to
achieve that but that was what its
earnest was and it was actually this
really cute article so find that uh
somewhere for folks
that that are looking for it also when
we do our next oscar episode mark i
think we just need to spend a good 20
minutes with you talking about why hoop
dreams was robbed because i just feel
like this is oh give me that soapbox
i'll talk about mr gaines and mr agee
all day long and just how that was their
moment and even it's one of my favorite
posters of all time it's just
i just and and it was so ahead of its
time in the way that they were actually
making this documentary and so kids go
back and watch hoop dreams what i will
say that hoop dreams didn't accomplish
nearly as well as space jam
was as the great yogurt from outer space
would say merchandising merchandising i
want to bring lucy in here too because
let's talk about our space jam swag that
we still have to this day lucy do you
have anything that says space jam or any
references to the original space jam
in your household i love that question
and i want to direct it to my mother
martha all the way in lincoln nebraska
because she wouldn't let me have that
stuff she was like anti-buying things
that movies put out there so
i think my brother got a hand-me-down
like space jam jordan jersey
and i think probably later on i took
that from him and turned it into a
jersey dress because those were hot
fires oh yeah jersey dresses
um
but no i didn't i didn't grow up with
my mom would not let me buy stuff from
movies at all
at all so i i had a depleted childhood
okay well if i get you i guess another
space jam jersey just don't tell martha
i don't want to get grounded before we
do the next podcast
peak of jersey dresses
going back to michael jordan mariah
carey wearing the wizards era michael
jordan dress
at his final all-star game that was
pretty fire naz perez any space jam
merch if we go to your palatial estate
what are we seeing from the movie space
all day well obviously you know i drink
a lot of water out of my michael's
secret stuff water bottle that i'm
holding up
um i got a tuned squad jersey
immediately after it came out it was
white now it's brown and it's somewhere
in my brother's closet because he won't
mail it to me
because i want it now that new legacy is
coming out obviously want to wear it to
that also can i just say not a fan of
the new uniform but maybe i'll change my
mind don't know i think they should have
kept the vintage vintage tune squad logo
but agreed it's i digress you know i
didn't need the the change up give me
something hopefully there's some easter
eggs for you know
there's some fan service for us that
love the original um
there's gotta be
yeah and obviously i had what else did i
have i think that was it i think i had
like a space jam keychain too but
obviously i have a bunch of michael
jordan memorabilia that i just
have
i've i've seen some of the mj
memorabilia and you truly adjudicate
yourself well as an mj stan i actually
have jaclyn that i
inherited is the wrong word but that i
that i got from maui's mom my
ex-girlfriend she had a space jam
reversible jersey that had it was either
the monstars or the tune squad depending
on how you were feeling that day
and it was too big for her and i worked
out in it one day and i think i came
home and she saw how sweaty i was after
balling in it and she's like okay that's
yours now
yeah just like i don't want it that bad
anymore you can have the jersey i'm
never wearing that thing again and she's
never worn that thing again to this day
yeah it doesn't work that way with girls
listen though this is what it is about
um about memorabilia i don't have any
tiny toons memorabilia or any space jam
memorabilia but my dad did work in
movies and i had one of the most coveted
items of my middle school i had a planet
hollywood
jean jacket yeah
for folks that don't know planet
hollywood was in the theme of like the
hard rock cafe it was the star-inspired
restaurant that they put in like orlando
and places and it was owned by like
bruce willis
and like sylvester stallone it was like
there was actual like stars involved in
it and it was the quint essential this
is not what you build it out to be it is
a crappier version than the hamburger
you got at tgi fridays and it cost twice
as much
but you wanted to have those planted
hollywood t-shirts you wanted to have
those planted hollywood keychains and so
everybody went to that place i wish i i
wish i appreciated it as much like when
it i do they i think they still exist
right in some places maybe and but the
walls were so cool and decorated but i
when you while you were a planet
hollywood i was like at rainforest cafe
like a real choogy yeah well ramsey's
calvin still exists yeah
planet hollywood does exist as well too
thanks to florida my home state it's
still around and i've seen it on the
road in a couple places but y'all are
missing the big one come on hard rock
cafe you had to go get that t-shirt from
whatever cool destination someone
intrinsically linked to your family got
you when they were on vacation somewhere
cooler than your family was ever going
to go and so you would get the classic
hard rock cafe logo with like some cool
place like acapulco and you're just like
the coolest kid in school yeah you're
like oh you went to hard rock hawaii wow
i didn't know they had one there
does
this house of blues count in this one i
worked at the house of blues
yeah that's another one with like again
it's like they make a museum in the
restaurant and so then they can charge
you twice as much right that's all it
really is yes so there are planet
hollywood still around london las vegas
paris malta
uh orlando malta yeah that one which is
a weird one
is my highest 23 in me you guys so i'm
actually dying
but wow i'm just gonna tell you now i'm
obsessed with getting to since i will be
in paris i want to see if i can figure
out a way to get there apparently it's
by disneyland in in like euro disney
yeah you need a paris shirt for sure
while we're on the topic of restaurants
and since we're talking about a
basketball movie i just have to give a
quick shout out to my second ever per
job or company that employed me it was a
restaurant in boca raton florida where
i'm from called wilt chamberlain's wilt
chamberlain the basketball player had
one restaurant and it was amazing it was
a bar an arcade and a restaurant and i
was a hostess there so shout out to
world chamberlain really wow
so cool that will chamberlain owned a
restaurant that featured an arcade
because you talk about getting the
all-time high score anyway we'll move on
from wilt's legacy beyond the court and
i will ask you one final question really
quickly here before we move on to wrap
things up here
look i've been debating this for years
and i'm now starting to soften my stance
just a little bit on the question
do we think we're going to see michael
jordan pop up
in space jam the new legacy i said
no way in hell in a million years and i
said that as recently as a couple years
ago
seeing the last dance seeing there's
just a little bit of a
softening of his image now but also
him returning somewhat to the forefront
also just to remind people who he is
because i can't decide if michael jordan
would rather have nothing to do with
space jam and that's why we love him or
if it's because he will insist on
inserting himself into the new space jam
somehow just to remind people who the
real goat is
i don't think we're gonna see him in the
new movie but i think that there's a
better chance than i would have a couple
years ago naz um
you know
this is a great question
i
i don't think mj would do it i don't
think he would do it in the same way
where
i was pr i would love to see him like
pop up at the end or something but in
the same way where i really just wanted
to see julie andrews pop up at the end
of mary poppins returns and she just
doesn't and it's emily blunt's movie
i think this just needs to be lebron's
movie but i would love maybe like an
angela lansbury and whatever nba version
of that is to pop up at the end just to
give me my little bit of like all right
you know a nod to the old one
um
i don't think michael's doing it i think
mike i don't know
if he's smoking cigars
i love that call that maybe at the end
after lebron wins and saves the day it's
almost like jordan meets up with him at
some random gym and it's like the end of
rocky three where they're gonna fight
each other just for each other not in
front of the whole world but just the
two of them so they know and then the
movie ends and we don't see who wins the
game or maybe that's where we get our
kobe moment you know who's also always
in the conversation of greatest of all
time it was kobe versus michael for a
long time before lebron was lebron you
know what i mean so so maybe there's a
number 24 somewhere up in somewhere up
in space made out of stars i don't know
it would be really cool if they did
something like that i think
jaclyn i am more holding out hope for
bill murray cameo yes
so
bill murray does what he wants
everyone who doesn't know this he
bartends uh
nights in austin when he shows up uh
yeah the man literally uh
is kind of beholden to only himself
so i could see that happening before i
could see michael jordan because to your
point
even if they did it i think it would be
weird and i don't think it serves it but
funny enough that you mentioned the
angela lansbury uh cameo in mary poppins
because that was actually originally
written for julie andrews right right
and they tried yeah they tried to get
her to do it and she basically was like
no and then you know you know i get it
but they they tried they were thirsting
for her they were trying to get her to
do it i like the bill murray call
bill murray would be great jacqueline i
agree i think we will see bill murray i
don't think we're gonna see jordan but i
do think you see his bulls jersey i i
think you see the the iconic 23
and maybe it's the looney tunes
referencing it but again we don't know
if with this new legacy if that is part
of current space jam cannons so we have
all these questions
that now even as i'm talking about i
think i do have to go see the movie
opening night just to just to have all
these questions answered i want them
answered to me before i read about it on
twitter right and also something we
should take note of is is what deal does
the nba have now with like movie studios
and licensing you know like the fact
that we saw the bulls logo and all that
stuff i wonder how much that would cost
today if it would be worth it for a
studio to you know what i mean like how
much of the nba is actually going to be
in this movie is the question i'm going
to be having going into the theater
that's a great great question and it
will be answered july 16th is when the
new movie comes out and we are gonna
wrap things up now with one last music
cue brian if you will
[Music]
yes for anybody wondering i do have one
quick piece of trivia but before we get
to that i want to thank our esteemed
guest naz perez it was so awesome
getting to have you back on the show and
talking about a movie that we all love
celebrating the nostalgia if not the
cinematic qualities itself uh what are
you working on where can everybody find
all the cool stuff you're doing so i'm
currently working on my cooking skills
so if anyone has any good very easy
recipes please dm them to me at nas pros
on instagram um
pasta made from chickpeas it's the best
pasta on earth i love it no if i'm
having gluten i'm having gluten no i'm
just kidding um
yeah so you know you can find me on the
rotten tomatoes channels at dodger
stadium if you're in l.a going to a
dodger game or like you said on the i
don't get it podcast um and yeah that's
where you can that's where you can find
me y'all go go to a dodger game anyway
because dodger stadium is just an iconic
place to see a ballgame but you also are
going to see naz working the mic she's
running around she's
she does a lot of work during those
dodger games but it makes it really
really fun for the crowd and gets it
really into it so you are a big reason
they should have given you a world
series ring to be honest with you i
don't know if you're negotiating that
yet the part-timers don't get those did
they win maybe one day just kidding
jacqueline
kidding he's still in my heart uh now if
you have a movie recommendation for us
maybe something that might be up a space
gym alley or anything else that you're
enjoying right now i don't have a movie
recommendation up space jam's alley but
i do have a movie recommendation but
since you just said that i am very much
looking forward to i'm sure a lot of you
have seen beau burnham inside on netflix
i think bo burnham is
just the voice of the millennial
generation um people born in 1990 and to
him to see him play larry bird in the
upcoming biopic to me i'm going to be
super stoked for especially because he's
like super tall um so that is something
to look out for i recently saw this film
it's a swedish film called border it's
97 certified fresh on the tomato meter
it's directed by ali abbasi i think
that's how you pronounce his name it is
one of the most original visually
stunning films i have ever seen
watch it high if you're into that kind
of thing it's about this customs officer
named tina she has like this
extraordinary sense of smell and she
builds a strange attraction to like a
suspicious looking man and then
therefore discovers who she really is it
is a romance horror fantasy mystery
thriller it is like it's one of those
films where you're like this is the
weirdest thing i've ever seen but also
is this the best thing i've ever seen so
check out border um directed by ali
abbasi because i think there's multiple
films titled border yeah oscar nominated
for best makeup
was it yes
yeah i saw that when that sundance i
think uh when that one came out and then
it did its uh oscar run the actress i
think also is an independent spirit
nominee she's so good jacqueline i just
recently saw it and i was like wow this
feels unrecognizable unrecognizable
that's why it was nominated for best
makeup but i think it lost to either
vice or darkest hour i think it was
vital i got to see i got to see this
movie jacqueline speaking of festivals
you're taking off soon right you're
you're heading over to uh france yeah
i'm heading over to france i'm actually
gonna try and make this planet hollywood
thing happen like i'm not kidding now
because my disney friends will be mad at
me for going to a place where there is a
disneyland and not trying and i have
like
uh three days before uh the festival
starts to sort of acclimate myself that
i'm there so you may it may happen if it
does i will put it up on instagram but
yeah i'm gonna be at the cannes film
festival covering that one it is gonna
be a lot of fun but a lot of work and uh
yeah hopefully maybe we'll be talking
about some films that did stuff there uh
when we come back i don't know we'll see
what happens also i just want to tell
folks there's a book that just came out
uh this past week or two yeah this just
came out you guys should check it out
quentin tarantino wrote a novelization
of once upon a time in hollywood i
actually got a chance to read a bit of
it early and so if you guys want to
check that out i would highly advise it
if you like the way he writes
okay there are probably a couple f-bombs
in that book
i did promise trivia before we get to
trivia you all can email us anytime rt
is wrong at rottentomatoes.com we love
hearing your comments we read them on
air frequently rt is wrong at
rottentomatoes.com follow subscribe rate
review do all that stuff wherever you
enjoy podcasts we always appreciate the
fan support from our certified freshies
your trivia question your right is about
the nba so michael jordan came back to
the nba and his chicago bulls set a then
regular season record winning 72 games
they went 72 and 10 his his first full
year back from playing baseball who did
they beat in the nba finals what team
did they beat in the nba finals that
would be june before the november that
space jam came out
the sun's i don't know that's a great
guess in 96 in 96 in 96 who did they
beat was it was it the nick
it was not the knicks i'll give you a
hint oh wait in the finals obviously it
wouldn't have been the name in the
finals it was a western conference team
and it's a team that is no longer
currently in seattle supersonics the
seattle oh yeah gary right
gary payton yeah john kemp
and i happen to be in seattle telling
jokes july 24th so it's is somewhat of a
segway i love it seattle needs a bat i
was just in seattle last week they need
a basketball team man
like those poor souls they still walk
around in supersonics gear all the time
just give them the supersonics just give
them that the supersonics yeah and the
supersonics and they make enough noise
with that so i don't want to give them
any other excuses obnoxious sorry i'm a
packers fan
we're still yeah yeah you all got some
some issues with the
seattle seahawks currently so i'll get
jacqueline out of this by simply asking
her hey jacqueline what are we talking
about next week we got a new movie yes
we have a new movie and we have a very
special guest i'm really really stoked
about this one guys because we're going
to talk to alex wolfe about m night
shyamalan movies because he stars in the
next one old and you'll recognize alex
wolfe from hereditary
he was in the first jumanji oh he was in
both of the jumanji's excuse me and yeah
i'm very very excited to chat with him
he is an uber uber film nerd and uh yeah
very very happy to break down
which ones of m night shyamalan's films
we think rotten tomatoes is wrong about
so it's going to be one of those
episodes where we do a bunch of stuff
that old trailer looks so good on the
beach it's so good you're just like i
have to see this movie i cannot wait to
talk to alex wolfe and to see olds i'm
going to see in a couple days here and
you're right as old as about somebody
who goes to a beach and they feel really
old because everybody else on the beach
saw space jam when they were six years
old anyway
also one of my biggest fears is getting
old so i love that he's playing against
uh it's happening to us all the time so
just sit back and enjoy the ride that is
naz perez that is jacqueline coley
perducy lucy brian perez behind the
scenes here our entire hard-working crew
here at rotten tomatoes and at the show
rotten tomatoes is wrong i am merely
mark l is saying thank you and until
next time
uh phylic an eagle
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you